your whole foundation of what deep dish
has too much foundation that's my
problem and I got a nice montrose
because I am a blonde rotated the reason
he kills every time he told me he had to
go to trombone lessons at 7 a.m. on a
Sunday
yeah you can't date someone that can't
come up with a better instrument
ridiculous you got down and dirty and
don't deal with any of the detrimental
damages
let's stop complaining okay well did you
have a better night than me mr. snapshot
okay I saw yours Normie you just went to
alfea's birthday thing I don't think he
was doing that this year
oh yeah did you get the Facebook invite
no no I don't think so
it's weird oh no it was weird what I bet
it was just like every other year right
forever got you drunk
Leslie hooked up with everyone yeah
kinda kinda yeah well you know he sold
that startup and so it was also kind of
like a big celebratory throwdown so
wasn't at his apartment he rented the
roof at that new place downtown the roof
like the whole roof well not the whole
thing a lot of it's inside look he
rented the car center outside
wait hold my meal you went yeah I don't
even know you and I'll if you were
friends we met in line it the in and out
a few weeks ago and line it in and out
me and I hope you went to college
together okay look it wasn't that great
all right it's just a classic Hollywood
party you know models falling into pools
celebs everywhere you could ride a tiger
you didn't even need a saddle that was
cool I liked that part of it but the
rest of it was just kind of boring first
of all that sounds amazing second of all
you when Zach yeah Neil invited me oh
come on
wait that's why you cut our picnic short
yeah I'm sorry about that
wait you guys go on picnics together
it's a sacred monthly tradition why am I
not invited I like the outdoors at me
okay
let's go let's go okay guys guys it's
okay for us to do things without each
other you know like we don't all have to
be there in order to be friends I think
that's my package for my grandma I just
got her a Christmas present but guys
we're best friends
nothing's gonna change that yeah got a
special delivery for Zac Georgina
you're a mailman Wow how are you even
conscious right now oh I know last night
was so crazy are we still on for that
picnic or are you freaking kidding me